pub
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
concert
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir eh bien nous l'avons ce magazine
georges de caunes et le président sastre
vous en dit le pourquoi ça c'était
facile et le comment ça c'était plus
difficile
alors je voudrais vous dire que
maintenant il faut le justifier
il faut le justifier comment nous on ne
vous offrant un bon programme bien
entendu et vous en adhérant nombreux et
en le faisant savoir qu'elle ne disons
que vous suivez régulièrement ce
magazine ailleurs ce magazine je
voudrais qu'il soit à vous et ce n'est
pas de la démagogie du tout je voudrais
vous dire que nous attendons vos
réactions
nous attendons vos suggestions ou vos
critiques éventuellement il vaut mieux
envoyer des lettres pour nous dire que
ça va mal ou que ça va bien plus tôt que
certaines lettres anonymes pour vous
dire que nous sommes pour un club plutôt
que pour un autre ce qui a toujours été
faux et vous le savez ce numéro 1 de
téléfoot
1 nous avons choisi un invité il parce
que la télévision le permet il n'est pas
ici sur ce plateau mais il est à nantes
dans les studios de faire 3 il s'agit de
jean vincent l'entraîneur de nantes
alors selon une formule qui était cher
ami rémy roca je me retourne vers vous
janvier 100 et je vous dis est ce que
vous êtes avec moi ce soir je suis avec
vous et bien remplie de fragments bain
bien rentré quatre heures du matin très
fatigant mais satisfait quelle
satisfaction alors vous savez je vous ai
dit la formule de l'émission tout à
l'heure quand nous la préparons bien
entendu vous intervenez tout au fil de
l'émission vous êtes un peu le fil rouge
et nous aurons vos réactions sur
diverses images que nous verrons très
bien la turn
ce premier numéro il fallait le
consacrer parce que l' actualité oblige
parce que cette agréable à la coupe
d'europe de football où nous avions cru
clubs engagés alors nous allons voir
successivement bien entendu les clubs
français dans leur prestation avec
chaque fois les réactions des
entraîneurs respectifs
ensuite nous assisterons à un festival
de but européen qui ne sont parvenues
par le canal des autres télévisions il
aura 17 au total et la plupart doubler
ou avec un ralenti ce qui fait une gerbe
de but et puis en dernier lieu nous
intéresserons nous jetteront un regard
sur la journée du championnat de france
qui demain reprend ses droits et avec
une affiche mais nous en reparlerons
tout à l'heure mais entendu vous avez
peut-être vu déjà quelques extraits de
la rencontre qui reposait en coupe des
nations
en coupe des clubs pardon à tout
seigneur tout honneur non à prague
mais je voudrais que nous jetions un
oeil neuf sur cette rencontre au moyen
d'un montage magnétoscope ou nous
pouvons mieux faire ressortir les
actions peut être mieux disséquer et
avec jean reynal nous avons non pas
revivre le match bien entendu vous
l'avez peut être vu sur antenne 2 mai
voire coup par coup des occasions quand
il a deux plats mais voici
25000 spectateurs à prague pour ce match
qui oppose les champions de france au
champion de tchécoslovaquie
ce sont les turcs qui joue en maillot
jaune et dès le début la rencontre le
duc la de prades inquiète les nantais
toute portion tir de roth de numéro 8
est tout de suite d'une tête de pelle
que le numéro 6
nous allons revoir cette action au
ralenti le numéro 8 s'est roth et vous
verrez la tête de telles que le numéro 6
que bertrand demanes détourne en corner
mais au cours de la première mi temps ce
sont les nantais qui vont faire le jeu
notamment par henri michel et michel cas
sans doute été le meilleur joueur sur le
terrain hier soir vous allez voir un
centre de puceau au départ de l'action
rampillon cetus au calme à l'arrière
gauche
un sens une tête de rampillon et le
gardien de but were debian les coliques
a bien du mal à se saisir de la balle et
c'était curieux car il avait les pieds à
l'intérieur de son but
heureusement qu'il a les bras long et le
thé au cours du premier quart d'heure
inquiéteront à nouveau les prévoit
notamment sur les tirs de barran kelly
michel et rampillon leduc à de prague
le club de l'armée va dominer à son tour
en fin de première période obtenant de
nombreux corner tiens minute premier
corner concédé par la défense nantaise
tiré par bill ce qui dégage en corner au
pelote deuxième corner à nouveau ce qui
dégage en corner 3e corner toujours tiré
par bilski une pipe de fiat à 10h pour
bertrand demanes qui ait réussi à saisir
cette balle nous allons revoir ce
dernier corner au ralenti trois corners
consécutivement
bilski la tête de fiat là et le prêt de
bertrand demanes
épreuve continue à dominer sous
l'impulsion de guy doucet qu un
excellent technicien c'est le numéro 10
il est peut-être un peu brutale c'est
lucas la balle en ce moment mais c'est
vraiment un excellent joueur
le voici le numéro 10 le meneur de jeu
de l'équipe de prague
et pourtant ce sont les français qui
vont marquer le premier but au départ de
l'action loïc amisse une passe
merveilleuse depuis michel et puisque la
technique de l'ailier nantais voit en
dribble une brosse et et ses louboutin
d'ucla de prague 0 les nantais ont
réussi l'exploit de marquer un but à
extérieure européen ce but au ralenti
regardé comme henri michel a tant que
loïc amisse soit lancé celui-ci efface
deux adversaires et du gauche une balle
très bien placé mi temps 3 0
c'est vite parti pour les champions de
france qu'ils méritent cet avantage à la
marque mener à l'échec et bien sûr en
faire le pressing au début la seconde
période et sur une de leurs grands
clients vient de commettre une faute sur
hot c'est le coup franc à la limite à
peu près de la surface de réparation on
dit quelquefois c'est un petit corner en
tout cas ce sont des actions très
dangereuse
gouffran qui va être tirée pas d'où sec
cai du sec que le numéro 10 un meneur de
jeu
[Applaudissements]
vi être sa reprise yves desgagnés matin
17 points qui éludent pointu égalise
malgré vargas qui était pourtant présent
nous allons revoir ce but au ralenti un
but quand tu pourrais peut-être qualifié
de bête car vous avez pu constater que
visait caler complètement raté sa
reprise va sig à dosettes disait qui est
bien placé la porte en clonant t on
laisse échapper qui rate sa reprise
riou fait ce qu'il peut me redonne là
bas la vie zec et qui marque mairie d'un
pointu du bout du pied du club prague 1
nantes un luth offensive des parois tel
qu il a tiré sur le poteau pourtant
l'anglais très difficile dans quelques
instants
voici au milieu de ces plantes et c'est
le numéro 6 ses qualités présent mais le
but n'est pas marqué dans l'au revoir
cette action au ralenti voyez pelle qui
a essayé de redresser la balle sans
doute pour donner à son avant-centre
mais la balle a heurté le poteau mais là
je pense que les bus de verton de man
n'était pas en danger
[Applaudissements]
ainsi le tir 2 sur le poteau de nantes
était là il y avait tous aux élus
avaient vargas vous allez assister à une
erreur judiciaire
enfin dix ans une faute de l'arbitré qui
va confondre caps est puceau d'aller
voir les propos avant d'obtenir un
corner
c'est fait regardez-bien bangas qui va
envoyer la balle très tôt un pour gagner
du temps c'est de l'anti jeu mais
maintenant regarder numéro trois du saut
tranquillement il va se placer au
premier poteau
c'est sa place sur le corner bas regards
se dirigent l arbitre qui l'écarta ils
repèrent quitus aux issers un carton
jaune et le désigne du doigt
tu se dit même si je sais pas moi le
capitaine michel intervient carton jaune
quand même pour tous ceux qui payent
pour bargas ça arrive quelques fois que
les arbitres se trompent
alors doucement donc pour tous au nous
sommes à 70 minutes maintenant ce joueur
qui se tient la tête c'est le numéro 10
12 m c'est lui qui avait commencé là et
donner un coup de pied à nice le
français a voulu se venger et actions
humaines mais antisportive un coup de
poing à larvik ne autrichien n'a rien vu
qui suivait la baille y consulte son
juge de touche
celui-ci lydie du mois je suppose nummer
health à l'allmend cela veut dire d'une
rose c'est loïc a nice on appelle le
capitaine henri michel le numéro 8
le voici à miss s'approche lui aussi à
petits pas il m'a frappé le premier
semble-t-il dire mais comme à l'école
c'est celui qui a répliqué punique thon
rouge c'est l'expulsion et les nantais
vont jouer à dix pendant les vingt
dernières minutes a mis ce bien entendu
ne jouera pas le match retour
à 11 contre 10 pour le domine la règue
verte rendement ne se retire de grottes
les nantais tiendront jusqu'au bout et
préserveront un match nul précieux après
l'extérieur c'est presque la
qualification pour le fc nantes
mais après michel ne manquera sans doute
pas de rappeler à ses jeunes coéquipiers
qui a 4 ans nantes avait réussi le match
nul 2 à 2 havel est
au delà lors du match retour à nantes eh
bien c'était l'étape on avait gagné par
1 à 0
de toute façon les nantais ont réussi
leurs débuts en coupe d'europe on peut
leur accorder la mention bien pour
l'épreuve écrite à prague
espérant qu'il ne ratant pas leur oral
dans 12 jours au stade 2016
marcel saupin ah non le match est fini
un but partout
très belle performance des champions de
france compte tenu en échec les
champions de tchécoslovaquie
[Musique]
oui jean raynal le dis très bonne
performance ne s pour le premier tout
alors je me tourne vers jean vincent et
je voudrais savoir jean si ces images
maintenant que vous les avez vus est-ce
qu'elles attisent des regrets ou est-ce
qu'au contraire elle provoque un
soulagement pas écouté je suis très
satisfait du résultat au départ et
rassurer pour la suite
bien que l'on ne soit pas encore
qualifié ça sera même très difficile
mais je me suis rendu compte que par
exemple sur le premier but sur le but
qu'on prend rampillon n'avait pas commis
de faute
rappelez-vous et sur le coup de pied
arrêté par la suite on a été surpris
certainement mehal facteur chance qui
est intervenu parce que il ya eu deux
ratés consécutifs de leur part est un
raté de chez nous c'est à dire de rio ça
fait beaucoup de choses mais ça sera
notre tour de jouer
disons de dominer je pense et deux de
leurs les oblige à commettre des erreurs
comme nous on a pu faire en certaines
occasions
c'était un test jean cette première
sortie européenne de nantes et je pense
que vous avez tout lieu d'être satisfait
de ne plus que cette première mi temps
qui a enthousiasmé le public français
oui très satisfait parce que faire match
nul à du clac pas que c'est pas facile
je sais qu'ils ont pris 29 points sur 30
possibles sur leurs terrains la saison
dernière donc c'est très bon pour nous
et on aura quand même l'appui de notre
public au match retour c'est important
je suppose en vous remettant dans les
conditions de la rencontre que vous avez
tremblé comme d'autres comme toute
l'équipe losc a mis 7 est sorti
oui mais c'est souvent dans ces
occasions là qu'on se resserre davantage
qu'on fait bloc et là on a su le faire
on a retrouvé des ressources nécessaires
que justement pour terminer le match et
conserver ce match nul vous avez
l'impression qu'entre l'an dernier et
cette année il ya déjà eu il ya déjà eu
un progrès je parle dans le fait de ne
plus être complexé d'aborder d'aborder
les matches avec autant de franchise que
vous l'avez fait là bas va écouter c'est
notre habitude on essaye toujours à
l'extérieur
quel que soit l'adversaire de d'imposer
notre jeu de jouer de respecter nos
principes et de jouer pour marquer avant
tout et non de limiter les dégâts
bonjour alors l'émission n'est pas finie
bien entendu récompense mais tout à
l'heure nous parlerons des autres clubs
français mais pour le match retour
pour l'instant c'est la confiance c'est
la confiance bien qu'on aura un handicap
sérieux avec l'absence de amis ce qui
est notre attaquant le plus percutant
quand même bon jean vincent nous nous
retrouvons d'autres pleurent nous allons
voir les autres clubs français
manchester saint-etienne ou plutôt
saint-etienne manchester si l'on
respecte l'ordre et du duc qui reçoit on
savait au tirage au sort que
saint-etienne n'avait pas tiré une
équipe facile
manchester n'était pas protégée et les
deux clubs pratiquement 2 parmi les
favoris de cette coupe des coupes se
prendre compterait alors on avait peur
de ces anglais et puis quand on les a
vus en tout cas pendant le premier quart
d'heure les premières 20 minutes ont été
un peu rassurés on s'est dit bon dans le
fond c'est pas liverpool man et
manifestement ils sont prenables comme
l'on dit en football mais au fil des
minutes c'est près de saint-etienne qui
a un peu déçu parce qu'on a l'impression
que le saint-etienne les années
précédentes aurait battu cette équipe de
manchester
oui face à manchester en rouge ce sont
les stéphanois qui ont tiré les premiers
sur ce corner de farizon voici la
première occasion manquée avec une tête
de santini snif était déjà bien placé
les anglais se montre déjà très offensif
débordements allèles de personnes qui
efface kenza et qui transmet coppel
puiseaux rapide ailier il kim tillie
hors jeu désigné par la [ __ ] allemande
ce bercy vers encore avec bathenay
montées offensives de lopez qu'alerte
trick délit qui dotera fameux centre-tir
failli tromper les l'homme et 500
matches
li en action sur ce centre-tir stepney
dont on disait que sa détente s'était
émoussé il était de l'équipe de
manchester vainqueur en 68 de la coupe
des clubs champions réaction stéphanoise
qui aurait pu être payante à l'origine
martelé me synaeghel lenny et tri qui va
servir barthélémy qui tente une jolie
pitt acteurs ses débuts en coupe
d'europe ils ont été convaincants puis
christian sarramagna ici qu effectué un
gros travail en attaque et fasse deux
anglais et santini du gauche qui
l'attiré côté dans le complot mi temps 7
à 0
une période où les verts ont tout tenté
pour accélérer le jeu et puis ce fameux
pipe sonne latence entre qui tire de
loin au dessus des filets gardés par
cure covic et enfin l'écossé buchan qui
lance coupelles sortie a pris dans deux
cures covic heureusement bâti sur un
corner et se soutenir stéphanois tiré
par bélie lopez d'avancé tente sa chance
de la tête au dessus des buts de stephan
et nous allons revoir le pèse peut
enlever au sud stettner janvion et
bétheny au milieu d'une défense anglaise
série ou veille 10 en 10 nov
les manques toujours 0 à 0 sur ce
nouveau corner stéphanois tiré par
sarramagna une tête plongeante deux ans
sans succès les saluons tout de même
cette action de l'arrière droit et puis
la 60e minute airbags décide de
remplacer barthélémy cas manqué un petit
peu de chance mais bon début alors que
l'ange rocheteau apparaît et entend
beaucoup de lui et puis nouveau but
hors-jeu à l'actif de manchester ici
avec personne qui efface parisot et un
centre pour il toujours là qui avait
trompé kirk o'bee on sent une pression
glisse de plus en plus forte pixon
toujours le voici
il était mcilroy qui frôle les buts de
cure covic on a eu chaud sur ce conte
ses fans ont attiré par sarramagna une
tête de bernay et tentatives ensuite de
dominique rocheteau qui cherche en vain
l'ouverture était dans le camp
stéphanois que la première décision sera
fait
eri alerte personnes et l'inévitable il
cette fois en jeu turcot vic
comme vers savent si bien réagir dans ce
genre de situation il réplique deux
minutes plus tard centre de janvier on
cafouille de l'éléphant et rouge bbc
nadel cette fois cette année
cette ligne
[Musique]
et pourtant il est beaucoup de
défenseurs de manchester le père tente
de prendre avantage en viande rocheteau
qui va être contré par biz stone janvion
et batna qui manque sa reprise
lui aussi contré par la défense laisse
enfin rocheteau step et la toujours très
sûr les anglais ne semble pas se
contenter du nul cha très avantageux il
faut stopper tout d'abord sur l'ailé
gauche encore en retrait sur coupelles
danger piasa sauf en catastrophe sur
cette montée de farizon revue issa
l'homme et fasse bkp et tente sa chance
ce qui de ce fait n'est très courageuse
et puis cette action anglaise qui aurait
pu être déterminante personnes curco a
eu des sueurs froides à l'origine une
grille qui avait centré sur epson est
encore ce type de gordon il toujours
déterminé qu'un cas thurgovie bien placé
tir de 25 m enfin les dernières
cartouches des stéphanois avec deux tirs
de santini et de batna qui vont venir
dans cette rencontre de coupe d'europe
qui aura révélé ou profiter des
faiblesses en milieu de terrain et en
défense
il perd devront se surpasser pour éviter
la déroute au stade trafford devant les
70 mille fans de manchester united mais
on ne sait jamais avec les verts c'est
un constat d'échec
c'était un match très difficile 3 que
l'équipe de manchester a su diriger le
match a su se montrer très pressant
parfois et il me semble que le résultat
est finalement équitable
[Musique]
avant que j'espère sera peut-être
différent puisque l'équipe fera quand
même obligé d'attaquer là bas et nous
pourrons peut-être les pendre en compte
mais ce soit quand même extrêmement 10
ce qui a surpris un petit peu c'est la
défense stéphanoise qui était autrefois
un excellent point fort on ce soir il
apparaîtrait que saint-etienne un peu
pêché par là je crois que les joueurs se
sont un petit peu énervés ont brûlé
parfois les étapes et naturellement il
ne faut pas tenir compte aussi des bus
qui ont été marqués par manchester sur
des hors jeu qui me semble assez nette
mais
je crois que
la défense s'est bien comporté tout de
même malgré quelques imperfections parce
que l'équipe de manchester aujourd'hui
était très près et cette attaque c'est
pas loin ce qui a manqué beaucoup
d'occasions c'est extrêmement difficile
parce que manchester s'est montré aussi
très vigilants derrière il ya eu des
situations qui auraient pu nous
permettre de prendre l'aventage
salimpour ici ça peut peut-être réussir
à l'extérieur chez eux pour opérer afin
qu'elle a été le meilleur joueur
stéphanois c'est trop con c'est dans un
match de coupe d'europe
il ne faut pas essayer de donner des
notes aux joueurs je crois que
l'essentiel est de faire preuve de
solidarité
je crois que les joueurs se sont tous
bien battu avec plus ou moins de bonheur
mais je ne veux pas dissocier
un joueur êtes obligés de barthélémy
comment je pense que andré barthélemy a
fait une heure de jeu assez
satisfaisante mais il est certain que
sur le plan physique il a encore besoin
de s'améliorer c'est normal et rocheteau
cette rentrée un peu tardif peut-être
une rentrée tardive non je ne crois pas
je pense que dominique relevé de l'oeil
de blessure il a fait un match de
troisième division je crois que c'est
très important de ne pas le faire
rentrer tout de suite c'est finalement
sa rentrée m'a donné satisfaction si
sarramagna un pardon sarramagna un très
bon tous les joueurs
se sont bien battus des robert herbin
quelle est la tactique employer pour
battre maintenant manchester sur son
terrain écoutez on va essayer de se
repencher sur le match pour l'instant je
crois que nous sommes un peu déçus mais
il va convenir pour nous de faire tout
ce qui est en votre pouvoir pour
arrivé à simuler les joueurs et je pense
que doivent comprendre que rien n'est
encore perdu même si ça reste très
difficile
est-ce que sur le plan psychologique
c'est saint-etienne de 75 qui étaient
sur le terrain ce soir
oui certains persuadé on vous revoit
bientôt je l'espère napier plus à vous
avez vu comment il faut pousser robert
herbin dans ses derniers retranchements
et encore on n'entend pas pour autant la
citadelle et je sais pourtant que vous
avez été ensemble au bataillon de
joinville et qui a des affinités mais il
est à vous dire ben sont toujours très
difficiles agréable mais difficile
et puis rendons lui au moins son prénom
il s'appelle robert et non pas michel
comme nous l'avons incrusté de talent
vous êtes moins vu sur les antennes les
deux autres matchs français à savoir ce
qui concernait la coupe de l'uefa
puisque lens recevait malmo et que
bastia recevait le sporting de lisbonne
alors nous avons envoyé pour cette
nouvelle émission un car de reportage à
plusieurs caméras à lens avec georges
dominique qui perdu parmi le public
lensois a suivi cette rencontre pour
nous là maintenant disséquer et se dit
en passant un public lensois qui est
vraiment récompensé de sa fidélité qui
est vraiment ajouté
oui pécs match lens malmö opté à peu
dans l'inconnu lens qui est en maillot
jaune lance qui dit on n'avait pas
encore retrouvé son rythme de la saison
dernière meta beauce maillot bleu clair
culotte blanche
cet environnement est important on
distingue du reste les portes et des
nouvelles tribunes tribune qui
permettront au stade bollaërt
d'accueillir bientôt plus de 30000
spectateurs toujours chaleureux
enthousiaste et sportif le coup d'envoi
donné par les lensois dans leur centre
vous dira et françoise c'est petit c'est
petit mais il ne devait pas se passer
grand chose au cours des cinq premières
minutes
le round d'observation se passait plutôt
au centre du terrain mais tout va se
précipiter regard des 6 tente de passer
son embauche les traités mais
irrégulièrement par christensson c'est
un coup franc 6 le type lui même une
célèbre joly a pesé
l'épithète de 12 ira c'est du délire
dans le stade bollaert
ap 0-1 6e minute une balle
remarquablement brossé du pied gauche
par six je lis s'élève plus haut que son
adversaire vous dira encore entre deux
défenseurs suédois et c'est le premier
but lensois
c'était donc sans bon démarrage mais on
était encore loin du but final est les
suédois a comme par exemple cette action
vont nous prouver qu'ils ne sont pas des
manchots
ici ces cieux berg le numéro 9 de
l'équipe de noeux qui a été arrêté par
le jeune delcampe et sebo larsson regard
des biens qui se charge de la sanction
il est très adroit et la transversale
envoyer ses tentatives de la personne
finalement c'est françoise qui a dégagé
coup de sifflet il y avait un hors jeu
et nous revoyons larsson très adroit il
a 33 ans est l'un des joueurs suédois
les plus célèbres ils jouent à stuttgart
la saison dernière fort heureusement
pour tempe et la transversale était là
ainsi que françoise pourtant c'était
donc un bon avertissement lorsqu'il se
montrait vigilant et même brillant avec
6 qui apparaissent ici une excellente
françoise mais bonne intervention de
yann muller le portier du fc malmö
décidément il se passait beaucoup de
choses en ce début de match dans ce
stade de bollaert
les suédois se montrer ses généreux en
début de match mais ils sont extrêmement
nombreux au centre du terrain car ils
ont un dispositif composé de quatre
arrières 4 au beau milieu et seulement
et peut-être malheureusement pour eux et
heureusement pour les lensois
il n'y a que deux attaquants de pointe
ici c est lui qui est aux prises avec un
de ses deux attaquants suédois vous dire
on remarque la vivacité et le meilleur
fonds technique des joueurs lensois
c'est un coup-franc cordon nice il
arbitre espagnol monsieur encaisse le
blond lensois niel leclerc une très
longue balle ici pour joly
et revoilà nouveau didier six regardez
bien ce qui va se passer
le critère à nouveau le ballon six va
nous voulons récupérer les suédois se
dégage pour quelques instants vous et
ils se réclament ces suédois car 6 à
contrôler très légèrement le ton du
match 6 qui n'en poursuit pas moins son
numéro un sens tout ferme l'équipe
françois farmine tête de françoise qui
s'est élevé au moins 50 centimètres plus
haut que son adversaire direct de
henderson et c'est le deuxième but
lensois
après ce nouveau festival de didier 6
1,6 très en verve qui s'est racheté
auprès du public lensois il centre ici
et peut-être même que sans
l'intervention de françoise la balle de
6 aurait pu rentrer directement dans les
filets de malmö donc 2-0 ap 19e minute
les actions lensoises et est donc en
hausse de but d'avancé c'était disons un
peu plus confortable surtout après moins
de 20 minutes de jeu
ici le polonais de lens yohan imax par
leur mobilité leur engagement et leur
rapidité des lensois dicter leur loi en
ce début de match fois même peu trop
facilement et réalisé ici pascal
françois haas qui capte tout le monde il
sert 6 sur la gauche françois traités là
mais les défenseurs de même nom ont
repoussé une première fois
et puis une deuxième fois lorsqu'il
jouait au dessus mais cela débouche
parfois sur un relâchement
finalement c'est compréhensible les
suédois peut être en profiter voici ici
monsieur berg leur avant centre le
ballon va pas revenir
l'arrière droit de malmö rothen d'epson
qui se porte sur le droit quatre autres
à une tête remarquable de cieux bergues
toujours bien placé les suédois réduise
la marque 2-1 en faveur de lens
ces suédois auront le savent et opère un
peu à l'anglais un jeu très large des
transversales des centres étaient
peut-être parfois terribles comme celle
de thomas soucieux berg qui est
également le mans pointe de l'équipe
nationale 2 à papa mi-temps malmö
reprenait espoir pour l'ancien
dramatique mais une vive inquiétude tout
de matane au but encaissé sur son
terrain peut parfois pesé lourd dans la
balance les suédois on l'a vu se montrer
inquiétant en début de deuxième mi-temps
les leur soit répliqué aussitôt ici par
vous dira mais qu'elle en soit
obtiennent un corner et qui elle pour
tirer ce corner qui est là pour tirer ce
nouveau coup de pied arrêté c'est didier
zix une toute petite place vous dira et
comme l'a rappelé à gap cgpi de géval
vie est en faveur de lens n'ont pas ce
qui par conséquent reprend ici c'est
depuis deux ans un corner que blandine
hémoise une petite et jibril
qui avait fait son entrée en deuxième mi
temps presque seul et c'est nouveau but
de tête 3 1 en faveur de lens cette fois
le déclic que c'est bien produit et le
fidèle et chaleureux public lensois
retrouvait son lance didier quelques
mois six montrait ses possibilités toute
l'équipe nordiste retrouvait en sept
sont européennes c'est-à-dire au moment
opportun
voici gély le numéro 13 qui avait
remplacé à la mi-temps io ary marque
c'est un joueur d'origine tunisienne il
vient d'un petit mais cbre club du sud
est de la france garde anne opère
également son camarade de talât qui
allait opérer également en deuxième mi
temps lille en soute se multiplier en
cette deuxième période voici football
dira une excellente passe pour didier jx
il manquait 50 cm mais l'air est
intervenue
l'occasion était donc belle pour cette
équipe de lens de conforter son avance
les camarades de croo physique en était
conscient françoise un garçon qui filent
comme une flèche c'est jean elie que
marquer le but totalement centrée qui se
précipitent ici à la papal
et bien c'est jean-marie elie quatre
buts à un quart d'heure de la fin
6 est venu rejoindre jean marie élit le
seul but de la soirée marque avec le
pied les quatre précédents ayant été
inscrit de la tête
formidable travail ici de djebaili un
garçon pile il fonce comme une flèche
les suédois n'ont pas le temps
d'intervenir janvier li n est pas qu est
très près en tous les cas il tente sa
chance de demi volée et c'est le 4 1 3
puis de retard pour les suédois qui
n'était pas découragée ici intervention
de tempêtes de vent hansson c'était
aussi les ultimes réaction de ses
footballeurs venus du nord des
footballeurs auquel il manque peut-être
un peu de vivacité surtout meilleures
fins techniques pour obtenir 10 ont des
résultats plus probants
dieu nous battre le numéro 7 de malmö
une équipe de malmö qui domine le
football suédois
elle est habituée aux compétitions
européennes
elle est aux trois-quarts professionnel
mais il lui manque surtout c'est suédois
talentueux qui se sont expatriés aux
quatre coins de l'europe
disons pour mieux vivre du football
voici un marocain qui opérait également
à la saison dernière à perdre des points
comme geely lille en soute a qu'ici avec
leur numéro 8 c'est à dire leur
capitaine richard crevier qui est sifflé
hors jeu lensois qui va permettre aux
suédois de se dégager
yann muller dégage son camp il est
immense ce gardien suédois un mètre 94
cm de plus que son vis-à-vis tempête les
dernières offensives ici des suédois à
personne toujours bien placé mais
tempête est intervenue et fort
heureusement c'est ici joly qui a dégagé
son camp in extremis en corner tiré par
hbo larsson un suédois s'est élevé mais
tempête c'était le même temps et à
dégager du poing up à l'arrière droit de
lens nous vivons là les toutes dernières
minutes
leclerc a donné un matelas
une trombe ici pour vous dire à en bonne
position
aucun partenaire n'était démarquer farès
bousdira
l'un des meneurs de jeu de cette équipe
lensoise optique osnr toujours 4 1 le
score n'allait pas changer pourtant
regardez bien le tableau d'affichage
[Applaudissements]
his modifier une passe ici lensoise et
et regardez ce que va faire didier six
pick-up le dos d'un petit point com
lundi entre les jambes de l'adversaire
il trouve ici et jambes pliées lignes
transversales et et la pitié 6 du corps
entre les jambes de l'adversaire en
cette seule souper il a fait oublier ses
entorses et son début de saison c'est
hésitant il put jambes pelli mais il y
part et finalement 4 buts à 1 pour lens
troyes plus de france lens est le mieux
placé de notre représentant dit toujours
qu'il faut deux bides avance pour être
satisfaits et attendre le match retour
j'en avais trois alors très confiant
maintenant on peut être confiant est
dommage qu on a pris un but puisque ça
aurait été merveilleux pour nous mais
enfin c'est une victoire très méritée
ils ont appliqué toutes les consignes
qui leur avaient donné et c'est une
victoire de toute l'équipe
ils ont tous très bien joué ça a été
merveilleux ci se battent encore comme
ça et joue de la même façon à malmö je
pense qu'on pourra se qualité alors
certes c'était pour la partie loges
maintenant quelles ont été les quelques
points faibles et quelques défaillances
que vous avez pu déceler ce soir c'est à
dire qu'il n'a pas eu tellement parce
que j'avais vu comment il avait joué
c'est à dire un 4-2-4 assez rigoureux
ils ont derrière ils ont joué une
défense en ligne très rigoureuse qui
monte assez fort et les quatre milieux
de terrain sans arrêt absolu nos joueurs
on a passé en faisant des longues
transversales en océan d une de on a
passé deux derrière on a passé seul et
on
le bonheur de marquer quatre buts et
auraient pu aussi bien avoir un 5e sur
un très bon débordement de 6 richer
krafchick maintenant le capitaine encore
tout chaud après ce succès renold vous
restez avec nous encore quelques
instants car vous n'êtes pas tout en
sueur comme des bulles on c'est comme ça
qu'on surnomme le capitaine lensois
alors dites-moi richard vous avez vu
deux fois je crois à l'oeuvre cette
équipe de malmö en suède alors est-ce
qu'elle a été conforme à ce que vous
n'aviez vous ré absolument le 4 4 2 très
rigolo ok ils ont pratiqué en suède de
l'onf est également ce soir même pour la
deuxième manche match retour c'est dans
la poche bas
en football
on peut pas toujours dire que cfm je
crois qu'avec trois buts d'écart ça
devrait disons que nous avons 80 chance
sur 100 de passer le tour ne sont pas
très déçu
nous on met vraiment impressionné par
l'équipe de lens ils ont joué très vite
et je suis aussi impressionné comment la
publique commune i have eyes on u maurer
oui absolument c'est nous avons cru
naturellement que la france doit gagner
avec un but ou quelque chose comme ça
maintenant il faut gagner avec 3 0 à
malmö et ça doit être très difficile
oui apparemment sur les images
effectivement ça doit être très
difficile
donc cette attaque de lens manifestement
a marqué ce match aller du 1er tour des
coupes de l'uefa
et puis ip bastia qui avec son petit
stade de furiani dit mieux troisième
division d'une division d'honneur fait
son entrée en coupe d'or ils recevraient
barcelone alors bien entendu nous
voulions voir comment les corses devait
se comporter dans ce premier tour nous
avons envoyé là-bas à l'aise courbet
avec deux caméraman et qui sont allez
donc voir à furiani
comment bastien a gagné mais met
toutefois en concédant deux buts
portugais ça ce soir des piles heureux
tout le public détient un public en or
qui avaient pu dû payer de l'or pour
entrer au stade de furiani sans main
froide plein tarif minimum ce qui
explique qu'ils n'étaient que six mille
pour assister à la victoire des bleus
que voici
comme ils l'ont été et qu'on va
peut-être voir oui les voies s'adaptent
comme ils ont été depuis déjà trente
cinq minutes sans pouvoir concrétiser
cette fois pourtant première occasion
ratée sur cette reprise de volée de
mario sur le montant gauche du but
portugais
tu voyais rien n'était venu vous dire
bien sûr mais aussi les deux vedettes de
lisbonne salif keita l'ex stéphanois et
zhao lamboley dont on dit qu'il n'avait
pas le droit de jouer ce match là
histoire de règlement et 8 ans toutes
deux veulent être en question dans pas
rater leur spectacle ni kéita numéro 10
toujours aussi décontracté et talentueux
needs au numéro 9 quand on emprunte
essence bastiaise qui s'en sortent mais
comme il le fut mais s'en sortir ainsi
en pleine surface de réparation ce
tableau un penalty est facile mureaux
plus cordes aux portugais quel est donc
marqué leur premier but à l'extérieur et
c'est djoko qui se faisait justice lui
même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
zéro pour les portugais s'étaient le
score à la mi-temps pour ben tiens qui
va jouer maintenant à droite il ne
s'agissait plus de lambiner krimo choisi
pour remplacer
il sera utile aux landais au match
retour primo avait laissé sa place à la
haye hausser la taxe bastiaise
paraissait ainsi plus tôt témoin cette
action partie de papy et qui va se
terminer partir de maillots en dehors
des bus du gardien beauté
jack sentait le but et privés dans
exactement 10 secondes après ce corner
tiré par un matériau rp d'une tête
plongeante fantastique de philips
[Applaudissements]
nous allons revoir ce bus ou un autre en
corner de mario et comme une fusée sur
félix 1
ça commençait ali et de doute un but
cela galvanise une équipe à partir de
cet instant là nous sommes à la 52e
minute du match les bastiais ne vont
pratiquement pas cessé de harceler les
but portugais par la rieuse par la quest
par burkhardt et 15 les deux arrières
latéraux qui n'hésitait pas à monter
très haut en attaque et défense
portugaise n'en finissait plus d'être
sur ses gardes sont des tirs incessants
des bleus qui essayait de faire dès
maintenant la différence
[Applaudissements]
le public était aux anges je ne pensais
plus haut prix des places et se trouvait
finalement beaucoup mieux chez lui à
bastia qu'à marseille ou à paris
j'aurais pu se jouer si les dirigeants
bastié avait pensé davantage leurs
finances que leurs supporteurs
heureusement collective a laissé
saynètes sur une once de jordan affres
litho qui s'infiltrait vous allez voir
la défense bastiaise pour marquer le
voici le deuxième but partout
[Applaudissements]
pour le sporting de lisbonne cette fois
cela commençait à sentir le roussi pour
bastia qui allait se montrer 500 pendant
une dizaine de minutes laissant les
portugais faire à peu près ce qu'il
voulait au milieu du terrain et se
montrer très dangereux des buts de
petrovic
comme ici sur cette action de fernandez
[Applaudissements]
heureusement qu'il y avait ce soir à
deux héros maillot de bain numéro 11 que
vous allez voir marcadal aile gauche et
que l'on reverra tout à l'heure dans
l'un de ces numéros des dribbles favori
mais aussi ses pics numéro 9
dif 1 auteur du premier but bastiais
toujours dangereux dans la surface
vous l'avez vu il y a un instant fait
l'x la des vieux de bastia qui tend du
principe que coupe d'europe ou pas
l'adversaire n'est pas forcément c'est
redoutable qu'on le pense et donc il
faut être décontracté ce qui était félix
mercredi soir à bastia décontractée la
preuve ce deuxième but qu'il va inscrire
à plein temps de maillot et une
[Applaudissements]
nous ce but sous un autre angle le
centre de bayod de ses conclusions
phoenix
[Applaudissements]
elles sentent
et plus
keane et ça c'est pas les deux but
portugais ils pèseront lourd dans la
balance au match retour mais tous les
têtes perdu l'idéal c'était bien sûr de
marquer un troisième but dans le quart
d'heure qui restaient tous les tiennent
pour ces quatre maillots en tête qui
faisait tout pour s'infiltrer dans la
défense portugaise comme ici pas de sens
et partenaires du plan nord qui aurait
pu faire beaucoup plus s'il y avait eu
un peu plus de réussite mais la
persévérance allait payer sur cette
action partie de 10 et qui se terminera
x encore et un but superbe permettant à
bastia de gagner ce match aller
[Applaudissements]
je sens votre troisième but de félix ou
un autre angle je vous propose d'écouter
immédiatement après
l'appli sur ce match et sur l'avenir de
bastia en coupe d'europe de cryptage
l'entraîneur
astier et celui de salif keita la
vedette du sporting de lille
[Applaudissements]
c'est grave pour que les portugais ont
marqué deux buts mais je crois que je
crois qu'ils le méritent il faut pas
enlever le mérite et de bastia mais il
faut parler aussi de la vérité de
l'équipe de lisbonne qui est une très
bonne équipe
au contraire je crois que ça mais ça ça
relève la vérité de maciel avait alors
gagné 3-2 cette équipe n'est visible est
ce que dans votre esprit ça veut dire
que c'est bien parti
c'est malgré tout c'est mal parti bien
sûr aussi que les buts contre nous leur
faudra ici et là-bas de faire prendre
- dames arc l'automne quoi mais ce sera
sûrement plus difficile que cela est
fait mais dont je n'ai pas 1 à 0 il
était venu sûrement ici à l'intention de
jouer série parce que vous avez vu que
provient en étant le premier premières
vingt minutes on a vu singer sont
derrière et que j'avais dépassé le
budget quoi d'être là bas ce sera pas
pareil il faudra qu'ils se découvrent ce
sera nous a préservés a sûrement là les
geeks il va se passer quoi elle a pas
selon vous pour moi j'espère qu'il y
aura la qualification
vous y croyez il faut bien y croire on
trouve ainsi pour la période y aller
alors je pense que c'est pas un mauvais
résultat pour nous quoique je pense
qu'on aurait pu faire mieux quoi au
moins obtenir et maintenir de but à
l'extérieur c'est quand même pas mal
comment vous vous sentez vous salif
keita ya longtemps qu'on ne vous avait
pas vus vers la fin du match j'étais un
peu fatigué parce que on a repris
l'entraînement de
à une manque de compétition on a fait le
de marquer alors on ne pense que d'ici
quinze jours ça ira mieux mais quelle
impression ça vous fait de revenir ici
en france ça fait plaisir parce que j'ai
vu que j'ai pas été du tout mal est
acquis mais non pourquoi d'ailleurs
serait-il mal accueilli salif keita et
précédemment je vous signale qu'il
s'agissait de pierre cahuzac peut-être
deviné l'entraîneur de bastia
et puis il paraît qu'un lapsus m'a fait
dire tout à l'heure barcelone aura bien
entendu vous avez compris qu'il
s'agissait de lisbonne barcelone c'était
il ya quelques années contre bastia
[Musique]